jetzt möchten wir sprechen mit dem profi
mit professor dr.med buddy holly hallo
schön sie zu sehen
sagen sie uns wie viele menschen in
deutschland sind von migräne betroffen
und wie kann diese spritze diesen
menschen helfen also in deutschland sind
bis zu 18 millionen patienten betroffen
das heißt es sehr sehr viele betroffen
diese spritze allerdings kommt nur für
die schwerst betroffenen endet nicht
weil sie den anderen film sondern weil
die im augenblick nur für patienten von
der gagfah sa geführt die alle anderen
therapieoptionen schon ausprobiert haben
das heißt es auf dem nachttisch
medikamente wie betablocker oder andere
medikamente etwas silber und sie müssen
alle vorher ausprobiert werden bevor
diese medikamente ich frage kommen das
klingt auf jeden fall nach einem langen
weg auch spannende frage woran erkennt
man denn ob man jetzt normale
kopfschmerzen hat oder tatsächlich
migränepatienten ist also eigentlich
gibt es gar keine schmerzen sagte ich
ihr mal bei normal wäre gar keine
kopfschmerzen
aber man kann es relativ leicht für sich
unterscheiden und die unterscheidung ist
sind die kopfschmerzen so stark dass ich
in einem meiner lebensqualität
beeinträchtigt denn das kann ich wegen
der kopfschmerzen zum beispiel mich
nicht mit freunden treffen über fällt
mir die arbeit schwerer oder bleibe ich
vielleicht im bett liegen weil sie
schlecht dann ist das ein hinweis dass
ich den begriff ist okay und frau
professor ich würde jetzt trotzdem gerne
nochmal zur migräne spritze zurückkommen
wie wird denn die genau verabreicht wird
einmal im monat unter die haut agitiert
subkutan nennen wir das das kann der
patient selber machen
er bekommt das einmal gezeigt
von seinem arzt oder er kann es auch von
anfang an selber machen das ist nicht
kompliziert und es gibt eine der spitzen
die auch nur alle drei monate gegeben
wird david ist sozusagen dreimal ich an
einem tag gegeben und dann erst wieder
in drei monaten
und in welchen fällen übernimmt die
krankenkasse
das ist relativ genau geklärt für die
gesetzliche krankenkasse
da gibt es genau auf medikamente die man
vorher ausprobiert haben ist das sind
die sogenannten first line therapeutika
das heißt das was mein erstes mal gibt
für die migräne dem werden normalerweise
für drei monate auf eis probieren
und wenn die dann nicht geholfen haben
dann qualifiziert sich das skript für
die grüne spitze und wie die parzellen
endlich schon gesagt hat man muss
mindestens hier die kleine tage pro
monat so ganz wichtige frage für alle
die auch kopfschmerzen haben was kann
man tun was sagt der profi also generell
ist es immer am wichtigsten wirklich die
richtige diagnose zu haben dass man
wirklich verfügt ist es eine migräne
oder nicht weil dann gibt es auch gute
medikamente nicht nur die mit einer
spritze sondern auch gute ab und
medikamente zum beispiel sie getan
es gibt natürlich auch hausmittelchen
ist dass die patientin auch schon gesagt
hat sie meine spieler starke tasse
kaffee hilft vielen ganz vieles aber
auch umstellung der lebensgewohnheiten
ausdauersport ist entspannungs vertrag
und sind so stressreduktion man muss ein
bisschen gucken was träger denn bei mir
die kopfschmerzen und dann vielleicht
sein leben daran anpasst mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren